the Joe Rogan experience I don't know
what the whoo thing is that's happened
in the last couple years
whoo like it's a second the whole crowd
starts it's like that's new that's like
some soccer thing it's like it's like
animals answering each other
communicating by with the wounds dude I
never even thought of that
that's so true the whoo that's a new
thing yeah I mean there's five or six
yeah right what do you think it started
when it's you know it when's the first
time it popped up down south like a
Kentucky or a North Carolina that's when
I feel like I heard it first like you
know that might be Ric Flair that might
be a Rick might be a Ric Flair is that
what that is oh dude that would make a
lot dad now you [ __ ] solved a mystery
for me that maybe that would make sense
if we can get some confirmation on this
somehow someone in a someone asked this
question on reddit if someone says
you've been talking about Ric Flair so
much that they might have picked it up
from you sorrow a moment where it all
connected like oh [ __ ] I started that
listen guys like that are important to
America
that guy's such he's such a character
Guinness prime with his suits jet flying
alligator wearin I was a WCW guy man and
Ric Flair was the man dude he was a like
he's a character that made his way into
what a thousand rap songs
how many rap songs some brick dude
there's a whole like like hip-hop
subculture involved with wrestling like
I mean I was like these cats that I'm
actually fans of Westside gun
and-and-and Conway and this kid Benny
they got this record label called
Griselda but the the Westside gun kid is
like a [ __ ] wrestling fanatic like
his more like he's like involved I think
he's involved with like little WWE like
doing merch and stuff like that I cuz I
see him putting [ __ ] together that's
like definitely got to be licensed so I
go that it's this is this whole
subculture of like this wrestling and
and and hip-hop
that's definitely made its way in a
stand-up to now you know they have this
podcast
the store horsemen where they all just
talk about Pro Wrestling a bunch of
comics Tony Hinchcliffe and these comics
lose on that store horsemen Jeremiah
Watkins right who else no he's not
I'm giving out false fake news fake news
that's fake news but it's not fake news
this is delicious by the way it's very
good it's delicious mad as companies
from 1773 son they started in 1773 they
sold whiskey during Prohibition for
medicinal medicinal purposes I didn't
know that but I didn't but I would um
not shocked it they so this company kept
making whiskey all through the
Prohibition legally legally yeah for
medicine so people that you know I'm
gonna need a little medicine I just got
a slew of new whiskey here it is that
day it's Tony Ames cliff Johnny Curtis
Matt Edgar Josh Martin that's right I
hope I said skirt is his last name right
is that right so I said yeah anyway um
so comics are really into pro wrestling
too they even go live these dorks they
fly out to like Wrestlemania and they go
in the are save live same saying yeah
same saying yeah it's become like a
Nautica it's become a thing that people
like to do like to go to these big
wrestling events and groups of people
whether it's musicians or rappers
hip-hop or stand-ups they're going like
for sure experiencing it exactly it's
like the concert experience why rappers
are so obsessed with Ric Flair cuz he's
got like 40 Rolexes Blair you got one
famous rant that he went on limousine
ride and jet flying yeah exactly you
know that kind of are all eight when
that happens yeah yes that's everything
I want in in the universe
it's inch yeah you see him now I mean
that the guy still gets love everywhere
he goes you know like it that I did in
my special where I said you know Ric
Flair and then I put the microphone out
to the audience the audience goes woo
like dudes you started that [ __ ] then
dude you started the wound
I don't think I did I think it was
already going on I think everybody
appreciates this guy it's like as you
get up we can't play this right we'll
get in trouble but this is the as you
you know you get older you and you see
things like this you appreciate them for
what they like you could think they're
cheesy when you're young but then as you
get old you go yeah that's [ __ ]
awesome the fact that that guy is this
amazing beautiful golden mullet with
those crazy sunglasses saying this all
saying all this nutty gold pinky ring
dude man that's a artist the guy's an
artist look at this that's the male soap
opera forever since back forever
children yeah yeah I mean when I was a
kid it was Bob Backlund and Jimmy
Superfly Snuka an Iron Sheik I don't
know if you could have really grown up
in America as a little boy and not had a
phase at some point were you interacted
with one of these wrestling
organizations WCW or WWF when I was
growing up and if you were like one of
those kids is really into like all music
and indie groups you know you you would
go for some like [ __ ] killer Kowalski
[ __ ]
you'd go you would try to find some
people that were off the beaten path
like do you know about this wrestling
organization cuz there's a bunch of like
weird little time dude when I was when
the House of Pain like was like early on
like you know but you know we were
experiencing pretty good success like
ECW had formed the crazy Extreme
Championship Wrestling I think that's
what a suit for out of Philadelphia and
they invited us to a bunch it was the
first time I ever really and I know it
had happened before but their whole show
was about cats cutting their faces open
and bleeding during matches and [ __ ] it
was insanity man and they had packed
houses I mean I think dude bought it up
like Vince McMahon bought it up and the
guy who owned it or I ran it became one
of the like characters within and I
believe I've it's been a long time I'm
old now I'm 50